hello there reject nation welcome to
part two of our reaction to the finale
for stranger things four part one if you
didn't catch part one that's up on the
channel uh already hopefully hopefully
we weren't done uploaded part two first
but part one should be up here on the
channel full length watch launch we'll
be singing with the time code for
stranger things over at our patreon page
for super sexy rejects cover a bunch of
shows over there where at the same tier
you get the options for reaction
highlights and watch along is included
please leave a like on this one and
thanks to the boys at prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's get to it
damn house
most miles traveled interdimensionally
just inhaled a bunch of that crap
stuck in my throat
please don't let that turn into some
horrible mutation
this is where chrissy died
like
right where is she
every death creates a gate i think
there's something in there
that's our boys
yes sir right on cue
that is crazy nice
that is so cool i have no idea how much
time is left on this episode
i don't want to think about it
just keep thinking it's that [ __ ] i'm
like no wait no that's right this is the
lock
it's so precious
you knew something so small could cause
so much trouble
i run it
ah
you knew it
what do you think you're going
military police
against the wall
now you don't have to be afraid of them
not anymore
is he one
please tell me he's one
oh my god you might be right
oh snap
that's where 11 learned that ship
like i said
we're alike
you and i
yeah confirmed
damn that's right he said it was
weakening him and i was like why would
it weak
111 oh my god she's a clone
brother and sister theories
two zeros two ones one zero two
zero
here goes nothing
there we go
so just the second you cross over you'll
fall on your head
this is the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life and i've seen some crazy [ __ ]
you ain't seen nothing yet everything
all right let's clear the landing pad
oh thank god
that was fun
[Laughter]
oh my god who's gonna get left behind
one of you asshole's gonna be left
behind i could feel it which one of you
doesn't have the core strength
after that man i'm so nervous
that
was fun dude
do not have a conversation with him
don't do it see on the other side
oh on the other side
okay
oh my god i'm so worried about you steve
if they harm one hair on steve's head or
chest
what
what
oh vac now you cruel bastard where are
you in the in between
no nancy
no oh vac now you crawl back to the pool
where barb died yeah
unresolved drama and guilt
coming for you
do you remember what you did nancy
or have you already forgotten oh my god
when i
kill someone
i never forget
[Music]
[Applause]
steve singing to her ear you gotta know
her favorite song dude
oh did one kill them all
and is she gonna have to kill him
sound design this season's great too
whoa
yeah
[Music]
damn it one you were so badass i know i
wanted to believe in you
wow
there's a reason he had an inhibitor
jeffy
kinda like arnold there
i know
what it's like
to be different
oh
right into the lair
[Applause]
eddie don't you like play guitar or
something in here yeah play some music
for her man
anything at this point with a melody
will do
what i tell ya wow
alice no running it's so big
this is the best thing a journalist
could ask for
yeah like you
i didn't fit in with the other children
oh my god
wow
humans
are a unique type of pest
multiplying
and poisoning our world all while
enforcing a structure of their own
a deeply
unnatural structure
each life a faded lesser copy of the one
before wake up eat work sleep reproduce
and die
good point
all
while performing in a silly
terrible play day
after day
[Music]
and i realized
i didn't have to
[Music]
i could restore
balance to a broken world terrified
predator
[Music]
i could reach
into others
into their minds
[Music]
they had done
things eleven
such awful things
i showed them
who they really were my god this is
crazy
that's why there's always after 11.
but my mother somehow knew
and she despised me for it and so she
left me with no choice
no choice but to ask
to break free
[Music]
i woke up from my coma only to find
myself placed in the care of a doctor dr
martin
brenner
[Music]
dr brown hair
the truth is he did not just want to
study me
he wanted more
he wanted to be me
when papa finally realized he could not
control me
he tried to recreate me
[Music]
[Laughter]
you were born
and i am so
glad you were 11.
[Applause]
[Music]
they're not gone
that's crazy twist man yeah
they're still with me
of course they are
if you come with me for the first time
in your life you will be free
join me
[Music]
god it's a whole story it all it makes
sense now yes
[Music]
i think nina's working
[Music]
stay in the circle come on get that
extra hour of free time
[Music]
ouch
oh
oh
it's painful
it wasn't supposed to end like this
[Music]
just the memory you needed
[Music]
it's crazy her mother saved her yeah
let's have a cue the synth drums
just like that demogorgon
that's a good shot
[Music]
oh my god
what the hell
[Music]
damn
wow
oh into the upside down
gnarly
vector
vector origins
oh my god this is crazy
[Music]
yep here it comes
comes that collection dante's inferno
zack snyder [ __ ]
[Applause]
yeah oh it's actually over here
that was like is this another fakeout
but not it felt like that was yeah
how's the end
[Music]
and now i don't want to watch a preview
no i'm already committed i'll be there
i'll be there
damn i need to watch a preview pull put
them a week apart otherwise we're fine
what a journey
yeah
did all that stuff with mike and will
yeah
[Music]
they were instrumental this ceiling you
have an hour and 40 minutes you could
include them all
if they weren't in this episode at all
i mean nothing's a complaint
necessarily no no i have no complaints
yeah matt that's crazy
all right let's talk about it that was
epic okey-dokey
that was a hell of a finale yes sir
speaking of time travel from the time
this is uploaded
because we we're shot way in advance
what's been uploaded
we are at uh
we are 50 48 subscribers away from a
million so
i'm assuming we'll be there by the time
this video is up so thank you guys in
advance if one person in every
continental united state were to pledge
right or to subscribe right now we would
hit it yeah there's a way to do it
and then you know get alaska in hawaii
just for good measure and i weird they
have a really big headache coming out
for some reason and a nosebleed starting
right yeah yeah and um some headaches
you're gonna have a vision
you're gonna see some trauma from the
past that you haven't yet resolved and
then you're going to start levitating
i've seen it all
um
well that was a hell of a an episode god
damn my nail or a midseason that did not
feel like an hour and 40 minutes i know
right it really flew by i flew by really
quick
surprisingly it was gripping i thought i
would feel an hour and 40 minutes
it's weird because like i guess it's
maybe it's something to do with the
proportions because it feels like you're
still getting just as much like both
character and science fiction you know
high concept action but i almost wonder
if it's just the effect of it's just a
bit expanded on all fronts and so
instead of
moving it's like this season has been
very cinematic but instead of moving
drastically differently maybe it's just
that they're giving each scene a bit
more time than they normally would in 42
minutes or something like that i found
myself at one point getting a little
frustrated
because i was going
why are we taking forever to build up to
11 massacring these kids
we already know she does it
what's taking so long
i already know where it's going just get
to it already and um
yeah that then when they had the walkie
reveal with with one on there
which was really obvious i think what
wasn't obvious was that he's vecna that
wasn't obvious at all wait a way to go
show that wasn't obvious whatsoever i
mean i don't know it wasn't obvious for
me at least i was always for you
good morning children
interesting
[Music]
that's vector
yes
that's right origins
cause when you gave the speech about one
i was like he's probably one yeah
absolutely no i mean i i always from the
start thought that there was something
more to that memory that eleven has of
the massacre i i of course yeah like
there's some reason why she didn't
massacre these kids
or she they maybe had it coming or
something but more moreover i was like i
don't think she killed any of these kids
and so i really thought she didn't kill
any of them i thought something else
might have like propelled her well the
fun thing to me is that
my initial thought was that was
i don't think she did it i think there's
something beyond that mirror that holds
the context but then what i appreciate
is they got me from there
then into a place of limbo where i was
like well damn though these kids are
terrible and they all seem to be like
that so maybe it is something where
she's pushed too far like they got me
wondering whether she actually did it or
not and then
yeah i thought it was going to be some
type of thematic compliment thing which
they were doing so i don't know if it if
it uh undercuts that theme of
you know because it seemed like what
they were doing was like trauma
repeating itself and because she has
repressed trauma that she is taking this
out on her life as jane hopper in school
and she's doing what she did when she
was younger which was like kill the
bullies yeah the bullies when really
what she's always done is is try to help
the the you know
benevolent or the weaker you know but
the [ __ ] brenner's gonna know the
truth then right he's got some videos
yeah
how many times has that dude come back
from pretty much being dead i mean he
he's i'm saying that like he knew
i don't know what he wanted
one to he wanted 11 to remember it this
way
well yeah i think he needs it it's it's
interesting because there's so much
in both the vector perspective and in
this nina perspective that are about
like walking head-on into
some kind of guilt or trauma or or
whatever that might be
and so yeah i i i don't know exactly
what the scientific mumbo jumbo is uh
but i do get that it's like yeah he
knows what happened but it's more about
her needing to walk through it to go
back and unlock those muscle memories
and find her capabilities once more
yeah
and uh and yeah i thought they made a
really nice dovetail i think the other
thing too like is that
early on i was thinking okay a lot of
the motifs are similar in that you have
the flickering lights and you have all
the kids with their limbs twisted and
their eyes gouged so there must be some
kind of direct connection but i never
would have guessed that that it is one
who becomes you know who is basically
launched into and imbued with just the
essence of the upside down that becomes
him which is a really sinister like i'm
still processing it because in this
moment you know it's fresh but at the
same time it feels like a really cool
book end
because so much rides on 11 and so much
uh is put on her involvement in opening
up that gate and kind of creating this
scenario
and yeah you do have this sort of equal
opposite in vechna and an antithesis to
her and it makes it a very sort of
personal thing between her and the
upside down which there's always been a
quality of oh yeah the upside down's
always been after her for a reason yeah
and i think this is at least right now
like i need some time to chew on it but
i think this is a pretty compelling
reason you know and to go to support the
hive mind and just that power of yeah
vecton has never been after 11.
i know and that's something too that i
kept wondering like that was my theory
frequently was like oh maybe he you know
was there you know earlier you know and
and tried to prey on her then and maybe
or maybe that's why he's doing building
all the gates because he knows he needs
something stronger to take her down
since 11 seems to stop it all the time
also that too yeah possibly for sure
because because yeah it makes me wonder
like yeah why wouldn't he have you know
tried to prey on her but maybe it's just
that it's like i can't prey on her until
i am like megazord power and he's
probably i bet collecting the kids and
putting them on his ritual clock totem
thing
to do some kind of massive energy surge
or absorption or something you know yeah
yeah so because yeah the mind flier is
the one who's ultimately
the
top dog yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one is
the five-star general so yeah not like
the origin of the upside down but i
think definitely sort of a a big
slingshot in its sentience and
malevolence
it is fascinating what they're doing
here i i think with season
it's not complete yet it doesn't feel
complete
right now
i mean i i rewatched the first three
seasons a couple months ago now then
immediately swinging into this
and
this this definitely feels like it's
in a lot of ways it's feeling like this
could be the final season when i when i
know it's not they said they have one
more season after part b is done
um
but
so far i'd be like this is probably my
second favorite season thus far
like i think cinematic wise it is the
best by a long shot
um just like season one story is just
it's just a perfect tail like it's a
perfect story to me it's i'm like that
that is just perfect it's just the right
size it's the right size and it's the
and like the the way they flesh out all
the characters you know whereas here
you know it's like i i would i wanna i
have to wait and see what part b is like
and then i might declare this my
favorite season b but right now it's i'm
like oh it's already definitely taking
the cake for
spot number two
yeah it's got aspects of my favorite
season for sure and i'm curious to see
how they stick the season four landing
because it's paced interestingly in the
way that they've released this and i've
seen a lot of people online echoing the
sentiment of like guys go to a weekly
model especially if you're going to do
these feature length episodes so that
you can really gather around them and
it's interesting to watch as they've
split it up because this right here and
now doesn't feel like it's complete
which is fine that's what a mid-season
finale is supposed to be and i get why
they broke it up here because you do get
such a huge bit of context and a big
revelation and now we get to stew on
that but it is sort of interesting that
we have just two more
installations long though they may be
and i wonder how that's going to feel as
a wrap-up and i appreciate them giving
us the space but i i yeah i'm very
curious to know how this is going to
feel as a complete season once it's done
but
at least right now they're like i said
aspects of the filmmaking and of the
themes and of the tone that are some of
my favorites i mean you can look thus
far at the season overall and say yeah i
mean you know like jonathan and mike and
will and argyle like they just kind of
trailed off right now we'll see them
again but you know like that's there are
things that are maybe a little less
refined here and there but what is
refined is so good
like this this could be my favorite
especially as like a fan of horror and a
fan of just when they're able to balance
out more character meat with
all that you see here and i think that
also the the plotting has been pretty
satisfying as far as i'm concerned
what was the thing that i was trying to
i was trying to figure out was are they
implying that there is
some type of deeper
connection genetic wise with one and 11
is that's that's what i was trying to
figure out because they were saying like
brenner wanted more sort of labeling
so are they some type of are they given
powers are they
are they genetically cloned are they
what are they they do refer to them as
brothers and sisters but i thought it
was more of like an umbrella academy
thing or or just a title thing
actually more than an umbrella
yeah yeah yeah or or is it just a title
thing of you know you have
like they're the ones with powers so
yeah we we call them brothers and
sisters
um because you didn't seem attached to
any of them no not at all i mean
he didn't care about his own family
either yeah i mean yeah he's got that
sociopathic detachment but
why didn't vegna show nancy everything
was just for us too i think it's just
for us just to title and yeah yes so
it's like she i mean it's a good thing
you're showing this but we're going back
to this storyline yeah
yeah that's a good question and that's
one there are aspects that i want to go
back and watch again for for the
clarity's sake because yeah i mean i i
believe it thematically because she is
the investigator and she's the one who
you know goes and gets in and talks to
creel etc etc so like there are dramatic
reasons i appreciate it and at the time
it was happening i sort of took it as
okay she's because she stumbled upon his
uh you know lair right
uh
she there yeah yeah yeah the spot yeah
yeah because they said like max max
didn't want to uh she didn't want max to
see that spot either or max implied that
yeah so she's back in his like lair or
whatever so i almost wonder if like
because he's a little more like
disconcerted when people show up there
if if it was like she's kind of peering
in on or given a channel to
something that he's probably not even
aware yet that she's seeing and maybe
that's how he becomes aware enough to be
like oh you're next on my list for you
know trauma camp yeah for recruitment
um but i i would have to go back yeah
and and check because it is convenient
to see all that uh but i mean i still
liked that was just a great twist um so
yeah i mean we got that covered and who
is this guy
he's the guy i don't i know i've seen
him in other stuff i know he was in like
immortal instruments or whatever and
other things but i most associate
doesn't look american he's british yeah
he's the he sings joanna
i feel
you he's the youngest sailor
todd yeah oh really i think that's him
yeah the young sailor guy who yeah who's
uh in love with johanna that's that's my
biggest association with you well he
seems far from american i know he's got
like he's got the accent down but at the
same time i'm like you you seem like a
british actor is really good at keeping
this out he's got uh he's got bill
skarsgard thing yeah yeah
he absolutely does um
i i yeah i thought he was great because
he always came across like a little
creepy but the show had me sold that he
was nothing more than some disturbed
orderly yeah exactly after even though
you initially guessed that as most of us
probably did yeah you're probably number
one
the show kept going for a while where i
was like no i guess he is just a guy
yeah sure why not just a guy who has a
lot of compassion uh yeah and i think
that's a benefit of the longer sort of
storytelling is you can't lead really
well yeah and you can suggest things
without being obvious about it you know
it was pretty obvious
without being
overly without the kind of obviousness
that comes with being confined to 42
minutes alone well i think it was cool
how they also were able to visually
realize a lot of things
um
of you know like what
would the with the gates when they go
through the upside down
the way they mess with perspective the
physics of it all like i was like i
don't i'm not really wrapping my head
around how this works until they like go
through it and i'm like okay now it
makes sense but i was like it does look
fine yeah it does look like it's a very
cathartic thing to watch because you can
feel it yeah and then you see the flip
side like how must have been for will
when he was in the upside down
and they advance their technology or
communication skills how to communicate
through the lights i thought was really
smart that was very uh revelatory that
brought it back like a lot of this has
felt like it ties into season one more
than the others and uh and the way
i mean more than the others they've all
always tied into season one but the ties
back into yeah that's that's why i mean
my hat feels like a final season because
it seems like they're like really going
full circle in this one season but when
they when they get to uh when they are
in the upside down
i like
i i thought that the flip of it was neat
because before was like pre-teens now
it's the teens even though they are
teenagers now the young ones but before
they were pre-teens other teens going
around uh through the upside down and
then watching like eddie and steve and
how they have this weird kind of bond
over the fact that they have dusted
they're both justin's big brothers
and they both like want to be that guy
yeah i love them like and i love that
they got like little moments like that
hey steve got his uh wish this episode
to finally be paired up with different
people throughout
um but yeah the nancy thing is a little
unexpected nancy and jonathan i feel
like after that like there was something
so refreshing in the first couple of
seasons about the way that things play
out between steve and nancy and her
getting with jonathan and steve kind of
having to grow up and shed some of his
more you know [ __ ] tendencies like i
thought that was all really interesting
and now it
it is one aspect
i can see how and i'll wait to see how
they pay it off i could see how that
might be sweeping and lovely for them to
be like no it was you all along but it
does feel to me at the moment like they
need something
for the personal lives of these
characters it is something we need some
type of room we always need to put nancy
in some type of romance and then steve's
always got to be looking for love and i
feel like those are the two main things
we've given those characters beyond
steve always having a new job and nancy
trying to be a reporter and so you know
i guess we have to mix up their romantic
tension again and i
i don't know it's one of those things
where i'm like it could happen and there
are aspects of them getting back
together that would be cathartic but i'm
not like oh it's gotta be like there's
no other way except for steven nancy it
doesn't even feel like conflicting
because you forget about like oh yeah
jonathan hurry yeah jonathan
doesn't even have like a one scene with
them talking on the phone i know yeah
they've they've made things of their you
know like distance from each other but
like the show wants you to like not care
about them it's kind of even though in
real life they are a couple they really
are charlie hayden and natalie natalia
natalia
yeah yeah
wow four years cool good for them yeah i
mean good for them i would love to see
some of that coming to this well i think
ever since charlie heeden's instances i
think that's really
that's i think it's the timeline of the
way things have worked out with his
character in the show seem to line up
with his legal woes yeah no they
definitely do um i'm rooting for payoff
but
so am i and uh so i like that and then
of course you know hopper and russia i
thought
the way
i thought they actually matched mcmurray
an actual badass
well and i think that works mainly
because
you've seen it go the classic road trope
way so many times of like i'm a black
belt and and they even bother to bring
up like i've never fought a real fight
and then it's a very uh uh uh
satisfying subversion and his grip on
russian you know well and also like
hopper's you know um this this mournful
state that he's in
and pitiful state
more than that it's just a really
disparate state that he's in to the
point where he just feels like cursed
and then hopeful and to have his prayers
answered with his angelic savior yeah i
thought was so beautiful and the buildup
to the demogorgon fight because that you
know you knew that was coming
and
to
i don't even think like the way they
they they are the relationship with enzo
and him is good
it's really natural the way they did it
um you can see how they became like
actual friends in the end
but uh the
the the fight was
was so
because not only do they throw it out on
the horror in this season they make it's
so much more violent yeah it's so much
more violent upside down [ __ ] around
like it's always the show's always been
like pretty violent but this season this
time i'm like this is like it was really
violent yeah
gross really r-rated yeah there's a lot
of stuff that is really like
uncomfortable yeah and and the way they
utilize the demogorgon that time around
was really intense
and uh it was like the coolest because
normally you fight demogorgons it's like
super dark and shaded and you can't see
what the hell is really going on and
there's flickering lights
and here they threw down on the vfx to
make this
imposing crazy fight in the in the
bright night sky
and the snow
and it was so cool like it was it was a
cool one and also like shockingly
violent at times yeah it was like
shocking like there was a couple of
moments there that i was like i can't
believe they just did that yeah it packs
that punch because too it's been it's
been a while since we've seen like a
straight demogorgon you know so you got
that build up and i love how they just
rung every last ounce of tension out of
that just push into the doorway because
you know what's coming and yet they
they're good at making you like we're
sitting there wondering like what's it
gonna be all beefed up and hulked out
because it's been just sitting here
feasting on prisoners all this time but
yes there was there was some one of the
earliest pieces of footage they ever
showed of this season was one with
hopper and a flame thrower
all right and i'm like
oh it's coming do you remember that
image of me
standing in the doorway yeah and it's
like he's ready to flame something that
doesn't i'm like where's that
when they're gonna do their thing blood
tests and their thing that in their next
season where they i mean that was the
thing when i hear the run time of of the
last episode of this season
which is like two and a half hours or
something
it it makes me go like why don't you
just divide it that doesn't make sense
make it a crisp three episodes but then
i watch this and i go i don't know this
was like i i wouldn't want to cut it
even though there were a few times where
i thought it ended but yeah but i
wouldn't like i wouldn't have this
episode in any other way yeah we've
gotten to a point where i trust as much
as it it does from the outside look a
bit like okay so we're going to wait a
month and then we're going to have these
just these two additional experiences
but i trust the way that they've decided
to do this thus far because aside from
yeah that theory of i think it would
actually benefit the show to go week by
week that what they've given us here
does feel like
a satisfying chunk to now stew upon as
we get ready for the final count can't
go week by week
with with the way they want to control
the run time
yeah you can't just one week have a
oh well if you're a week by week on
netflix though oh yeah yeah cause it
wouldn't matter for some reason i was
like you can't just put this on a
network television no but the thing is
that we don't have those concerns yeah
yeah on netflix you can mess with that
though yeah or or release some do arcane
and release them like an act at a time
or something like i'm glad that they've
split it up to some variety but this is
more than ever and i feel like the
previous seasons of stranger things even
have to me i've been more content with
them as a binge as a one kind of big
unit but this was like
most of these are show stop like
literally a few maybe one episode to me
right now feels like a transitional or
like a bunch of place setting or
whatever uh and not in a bad way but
just like each of these feels like its
own piece i get that it's part of a
bigger story it feels like that but each
one is a piece yeah and so i feel like
you could you know space them out that
way but you know that's just a little
thing
100 minutes where is this where's the 50
minute mark of this episode
what do we got the chess game i'm able
to do a part one part maybe just make it
full
yeah yeah just cut down in ten minutes
yeah five minutes of footage from this
hour and four episodes
mostly all rainbow room stuff
um but i don't know is there anything
we're missing i don't think so really i
mean
you know and then nancy being left there
i think that's what i mean barbara's
often is like the forgotten one other
than nancy is the only one who never
forgets and this there's a reason why
uh so that's another thing i feel like
oh they're really the another thing just
makes you think they're time
does bring back season one a lot you
know like the second she was in the pool
and like move barbs yeah
and with yeah so with barb uh with
having to confront that like that's
something that's always weighed on her
and has been a big motivating factor and
that's a meta thing they know the secret
play the music maybe that's when
jonathan comes and he's that's the
reason why he's the one because he would
know what song
yes they're gonna call him in california
what's her favorite song dude i mean
they're on their way to the to
tina yeah
maybe l can beam it in
but i mean even that feels like a little
bit of a meta nod because after season
one i remember people being like why is
there so little mention of what happened
to barb even though they do but yeah
like i thought even that was a nice sort
of way of being like yeah we're bringing
everything full circle and i thought it
made that better because it's like yeah
like a lot you are the one who's like
kind of kept her memory alive and yet
also this character has kind of
uh uh been done a disservice by just the
circumstances true um
yeah i don't know like we'll see two
subscribers away from him
[Music]
we have to go live right after this uh
but yeah i mean with nancy uh um uh
i guess the thing
to circle back one more time is like i i
root for a love story because i feel
like each of these seasons has had that
element plugged in and maybe that's the
one thing that's kind of missing here is
everyone's kind of in relationship
turmoil and you get that heart swell
when joyce sees hopper again which was
really lovely but i feel like you know
i feel like they're floundering on
finding a love story you can root for
whereas i feel like the previous seasons
have had that for somebody or for a few
people at least and so i hope that maybe
the music you know when when that
happens could maybe because again this
season is good at taking whatever i
might have been griping about last time
and then addressing it the next time so
uh you know maybe the music and
everything will bring that story into
clearer focus but
but uh yeah i don't know it makes sense
to have nancy uh
be
in the clutches you know for various
reasons now
yeah
a lot of good ensemble bits too a lot of
good dust and work and [ __ ] out eric is
fully part of the club
that's that was refreshing yeah
we'll see i mean we get the next one in
a couple weeks yeah well
it's not too far yeah we got to check
back here with jonathan and them and we
also got to check back in with uh yeah
somebody else wasn't in this episode too
uh they were the kids we don't talk
anymore we gotta we gotta all right
thank you for watching check back in
july when the show comes back and we
come back and and thank you love you
everybody
[Music]
you